foreign
[Music]
hello everybody Welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua Fields Milburn
unfortunately Ryan Nicodemus is sick
today
he has the great Siberian itch
what
that is that a real thing no there can't
be
well it's Alan Watts's I'm just trying
to keep Alan Watts alive here but don't
worry the beautiful voices you hear on
the podcast right now we've got malabama
here hi everybody TK Coleman what it is
we got the rest of our team here in the
studio as well and a very special guest
we'll introduce you to her in a moment
coming up today on this free public
minimal episode we're talking to a
listener about unhealthy family
relationships we also have an
outstanding lightning round segment a
live stream question a listener tip for
you and much more you can check out the
full two hour maximal edition of episode
379 where we answer four times the
questions and we dive deep into several
simple living segments that private
podcast episode is out right now at
patreon.com the minimalists your support
keeps our podcast and YouTube Channel
100 advertisement free because
advertisements suck let's start with our
callers y'all if you have a question or
comment for our show well give us a call
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcast that the minimalists.com our
first question today is from Jessie
my name is Jesse from Kingston Ontario
Canada I'm a mother of two under three
years old and I'm struggling with
letting go of my expectations that my
parents and my mother-in-law should be
helping us more raise our children I
never expected to feel this way I always
just assumed that they would be around
more to offer help in ways of
babysitting and just providing general
relief from the everyday demands of
parenting young children
even when I asked for help my requests
are often met with we are busy or have
other plans at the times you need help I
try to schedule far in advance but even
these plans sometimes fall through
I'm happy they have active lifestyles of
their own but I wish they would show up
more as grandparents for our children
can anyone relate or provide advice on
letting go of these expectations
so we're talking about letting go of
expectations and joining us in the
studio today for this whole episode is
Network wild she's a therapist she's a
relationship ship expert and she's also
the author of this new book it's called
drama free and I have a hard copy before
she has one
if she came in like wait how'd you get
that
the book comes out February 28th we'll
put a link to it in the show notes I
would encourage you to go pre-order it
now because we're going to be diving
deep into this in fact Nedra you can see
my copy of the book is all marked up and
we have a lot of tabs to cover today I'm
gonna lean on you a lot because I need
some relationship clutter advice we need
to declutter some of these relationships
I think we start with with Jesse's
question here
she has um some expectations that she's
been clinging to and of course these
expectations which you write about in
the book our expectations are sort of a
a yardstick a measurement for our future
regrets or our future disappointments
the more expectations I pick up the more
I'm going to be disappointed by the
people around me and so on page 145 of
your book chapter 11 you talk about
troubleshooting relationships with
parents although I don't know that this
is necessarily troubleshooting the
parents as so much as it is Jesse's
expectations of her loved ones
um I hear a lot of expectation there and
I hear that there is this need to
control how other people grandparent
we have expectations it makes sense but
it can be harmful in our relationships
with other people I wonder what this
person could do maybe solicit some help
from friends or neighbors or you know
maybe paid resources and not put all of
that expectation on their parents you
know parents have an idea of how they
want to live too and it sounds like
those parents have a really busy life
and so I think it's not so much about
like letting them go but living with
having those expectations and maybe
having to create a life for your kids
where there are other people who help
with that grandparenting aspect it
doesn't have to be a grandparent it
could be a child care provider it could
be your friend's mom it could be
um the lady down the street there are so
many other people who could support you
and focusing on that one person and
having that expectation will certainly
make you very resentful about the
relationship hmm
[Music]
you know sometimes when we have
expectations that create a lot of Misery
we tend to focus on getting ourselves to
get rid of the expectation or getting
other people to conform to the
expectation but we can also work
together with people and say hey how can
we co-create an expectation that works
for everyone here and so
you know there's there's the opportunity
to sit down with them and say hey I
would love to have you more involved
and I don't know what that looks like I
have my assumptions and you have your
lifestyle and there's been some conflict
there's been some disagreement but I
would just like to know what can I
expect you know what what would you be
willing to do and then we can create an
agreement and we can transcend
assumptions and expectations and
actually proceed on the basis of
agreements and once you have an
agreement you know what to expect you
know I think quite often people don't
know that we have expectations of them
in fact we don't even know that I have
an expectation of nedron I have a
expectation of TK and Mallory and Jordan
and Sean and they don't know my
expectations how could they possibly
ever live up to my expectations if I
haven't set them forth and said hey here
are my expectations and even then having
too many expectations for anyone is a
recipe for that disappointment because
eventually if I have a hundred
expectations for Jordan and he meets 99
of them what do I think about the one
that he didn't how dare you Jordan
I can't believe you didn't meet my
expectations but I did all these other
things yes but I am so focused narrowly
on that one thing that I expected of you
would you be willing to talk about that
a bit
we think mind reading is love we think
of love as this person can Intuit what I
want what I need I don't have to tell
them we see it all over TV like oh they
did these wonderful things and I said
nothing when in real relationships we
have to speak our expectations a ton we
have to repeat those expectations so
when you have the expectation of this is
what I thought grandparenting would look
like for us in this relationship it's
important to have that conversation
because what you're responding to is
something that hasn't been said
and when you're doing that is not fair
to you because your expectation isn't
being met and it's not fair to the other
person because they have no clue what
they should be doing so having that
clarifying conversation and being open
to a person having a different
perspective that can be your expectation
and the other person has the option to
not meet it but perhaps
maybe your parent says hey I'll help you
pay for child care because I want to do
these other things but having that
conversation
certainly creates a space from for some
sort of community but without it you
know there's there's no options I find
it interesting in relationships how
strangers you know maybe me and my DM
and you know therapists and friends and
everyone else are so aware of the issues
we have with people but the person we
have the issue with is completely
unaware oh so we're going to these
outside sources to resolve this internal
issue and it's really important that
whatever we're thinking it's you know
it's cool to process and talk to other
people but make sure you're taking that
information back to the relationship and
actually having those conversations
because that's where the change can
happen it's not just oh I need to tell
everyone and get everyone's opinion it's
I'm having this issue how do I resolve
it with the person because sometimes we
have an expectation that they're not
gonna like it they're going to say this
I don't know
and it would be so interesting to hear
how they respond to this concern because
maybe you're exhibiting that you don't
want help
how do we have those conversations in
the relationship and be open to the
conversation not going in the way that
we might hope
I think part of that is also
yes you might have your own expectations
but do you understand what their
expectations are as well this is a
two-way street right and so they might
have certain expectations of you you're
unaware of and that could be tainting
the relationship the subtitle of your
book is a guide to managing unhealthy
family family relationships unhealthy
family relationships that's a two-way
street as well we can very easily make a
relationship unhealthy if we have a
bunch of unnecessary expectations or
toxic expectations or expectations that
can't be met mm-hmm
Wayne Dyer tells the story of how he
bought a pair of a pack of cookies at
the airport and he gets on the plane he
sits the cookies next to him and he
starts to you know eat them and the
person next to him takes a cookie and
they eat it and he thinks to himself
this person is out of their mind but he
doesn't say anything right he just I'm
gonna play it cool and so he takes a
cookie and the person next to him takes
another cookie and he looks at them
hoping that just by seeing them uh
they'll they'll relax and they just
smile nervously and he smiles and they
eat the cookies and so after this goes
on and all the cookies are gone he
decides he's going to confront this
person and when he looks he notices that
the other person actually had bought the
same pack of cookies that he had and it
was that person's cookies rather than
his own and he still had his own in his
bag and he realized that he was the
Cookie Thief all along all along and
although he thought the um he was being
patient with the other person they were
the one being patient with him so
sometimes we think we're being the
bigger person and that other person is
being the bigger person because we're
not communicating those needs and
expectations sometimes we're the Cookie
Thief
Matthew you have a whole chapter in here
I was reading to my daughter this
weekend my daughter's nine and uh we
were talking about in-laws what's it
called it's called navigating in in-laws
and first off she was like what's an
in-law I guess I don't use that language
around her at all yeah her grandparents
are my in-laws right and um I always
think it's fascinating and you say
something in your book about it's not
your responsibility to turn your in-laws
into the ideal in-laws and I think vice
versa right can we talk a bit because I
think part of Jesse's question here it
has to do with the in-laws and her
relationship with them
people have personalities and it's not
our job to change them and when we move
into extended family relationships or
in-law relationships we sometimes have
an idea of what that family should be
like and when they don't fit that idea
we try to make them that way your mother
isn't this your dad isn't that it's like
they're just being who they are and it's
your job to walk into the situation and
sort of be in relationship with them we
do that you know hopefully well in
working relationships we do that well in
public with strangers like it's not
about changing other people it's
sometimes just how do I be in a
relationship with this person however
they are especially if the behaviors
aren't toxic or anything it's just like
you know this person is louder or this
person tends to you know maybe over talk
others maybe those are things you start
to notice and say maybe this is an
opportunity for me to crack
disassertiveness maybe this is an
opportunity for me to think about why
this is bothering me a louder voice than
I'm used to hearing but going into the
situation and saying these people need
to change to accommodate what I need
from them that is going to be tough we
can make a request we certainly can you
know offer some examples of what might
be supportive to us but they have the
option to
not do any of those things and to
continue being themselves yeah yeah I I
think about Jesse's question in
particular she's talking about letting
go of the expectations because she has
formed some that seem to not be serving
her anymore and so it's almost like
almost like she's getting behind the why
here she understands that hey I have
certain expectations of my in-laws with
my parents of family members of
community of whomever and those
expectations it's not it's wrong to have
them you're not bad for having them in
fact you've been acculturated to pick up
all these expectations throughout your
life but if you realize hey it's no
longer serving me clinging to that same
expectation will drag me in a direction
that makes me miserable and by the way
I'll just get Karine from one side of an
expectation to another the more
expectations I pick up this cease to
serve me it's okay to have any
expectation but why as you just said why
do I have this expectation of my in-laws
why do I think they should be there okay
I know I need some one to show up for me
but why do I assign that role to this
person and can I let that go just not by
letting go of the whole expectation but
can I loosen my grip on it as you've
Illustrated already maybe it's not your
in-laws job to do the things you want
them to do but maybe you can still get
support from someone else in the
community whether it's a child care
worker or some other family member that
can serve you or maybe they can serve
you as well your in-laws but not in the
capacity you originally thought they
might be able to with family our
expectation based on the role it's much
higher it's like this is a brother and
these are all the things Brothers do
this is a grandparent these are all the
things that grandparents do
this grandparent is a person and it
sounds like this grandparent has an
active thriving life that doesn't
include Child Care daily or weekly or
whatever that is and so we have to
accommodate that no matter what the role
is
this is a person
we have to remove the role and the
expectations we assign to those things
because you know I think about when
people have relationship issues with
their parents and you know it could be a
parent who has some
unhealthy traits they they yell at you
they're demeaning and it's like but it's
my dad it's like but your dad is yelling
at you this person being your dad
doesn't mean that they won't do these
things your dad is a person he has a
story he has stuff it sounds like he has
some things he should work through but
also you can't because he's a dad say
that he can't do these things he is a
person who happens to have had a baby
yes and you are the baby you know these
are grandparents who have grandchildren
but it doesn't mean you know what
because I'm a grandparent there are
things I now have to do as a human it's
still a human I think about
um
when I was younger some of my friends
started to have babies and I would think
like oh my gosh we're the same aging you
have a baby whoa I don't think I could
have a baby you know because it's it's
like this is a person and I see the
person and it's like I never thought of
moms wearing those shoes or I never
thought of you know like but it's like
this person is a mother and as a
manifestation of that you will do human
things because you're a human first you
just happen to have a child or be a
sister and have these roles and we have
to recognize a human within those roles
it's a great line in your book parents
are people with children and how simple
is that but we don't think about that we
just think that parents are parents with
children like they are that's their role
and that's it we've siled them into that
role right as opposed to like well yeah
this is a normal person they happen to
have children it doesn't change the
flaws they may have had before forehand
in fact if anything it can often amplify
those flaws someone who's terrible with
money can become more terrible with
money once once they have fewer
resources right and so what's
fascinating here about what you're
talking about is we often put people in
a box this is your role and it removes
the humanity from that person Jesse I'd
love to send you a copy of drama free
and advanced copy since it comes out
February 28th if you're watching the
video version I'll hold up the book here
so you can see on camera we'll also put
a link to it in the show notes so you
can pre-order it like let's get nedra's
book back on the New York Times
bestseller list all right y'all Ryan's
not here so I need to tell you that it
is time for the lightning round this is
where we answer your questions from Tick
Tock you can follow the minimalists on
Tick Tock Instagram Facebook and Twitter
at the minimalists now during the
lightning round this is where TK and I
do our best answer questions with a
short shareable less than a 140
character response so we have 60 seconds
to do so our lightning round question
today is from Barbara
how do we approach The Inheritance
conversation without being disrespectful
to family members okay so TK is going to
be my John Stockton for this episode
he threw an assist to me he's gave me
five minimal maxims yesterday for this
episode minimalist I'm borrowing one of
them put 60 seconds on the clock for me
here is my minimal Maxim assisted by TK
Coleman the truth hurts
but it also heals I'm reminded of my
favorite David Foster Wallace quote he
says the truth will set you free but not
not until it's had its way with you hmm
and that's what the truth does it is
painful it can hurt us but it can also
heal us it can heal us from our own
insecurities because that's what this
conversation is really about here we
want to have an inheritance conversation
we want to have a difficult or
uncomfortable conversation and so we
avoid those things how by skirting the
truth we circumnavigate the truth we
approximate the truth we pretend that
this is close enough to the truth or we
just avoid the truth all together and
when we do that we also we we create
some resentment we create some tension
in our relationships and when we create
that resentment our relationship it
doesn't heal us it harms us
oh do you hear that new ding in the
background Professor Sean he he swapped
out our shot clock buzzer that was
annoying some people this is so loud
with a very calm Eckhart Tolle extended
Ding and that's let me know my 60
seconds is up the truth hurts but it
also heals
TK what do you got for us hmm
the truth
lovingly conveyed can never be
disrespectful whenever I'm sharing my
heart my personal Maxim is don't be a
jerk but also don't be manipulated by
the fear that other people will label
you as a jerk for being honest about how
you really feel the Don't Be a Jerk part
simply means this you can convey a
disappointing truth without using a
disrespectful tone the truth is not a
weapon that we use to make people feel
small or stupid the truth is a tool of
transformation and when we give them
truth we are giving them a gift and that
allows us to speak the truth graciously
but the don't be afraid part means that
sometimes even when you are nice the
truth is not nice and sometimes that
truth will make people feel as if you
are a villain for speaking it and
sometimes you have to be willing to be a
villain in other people's story in order
to speak the truth that makes it
possible for them to be the hero of
their own hmm
look at that TK Coleman
there's one other line you sent me that
I'd like to expand on real quick and you
started to expand on a little bit there
the truth isn't always nice but neither
is being politically correct and I want
to be clear about that because being
truthful doesn't mean battering your
friends and family with your preferences
with your beliefs here's what I believe
and therefore you should believe it too
yeah this is my preference so it should
also be your preference I like eating at
this restaurant so TK you better like
eating there as well I'm not gonna
batter you with my truth yeah right
they're situational truths when I say my
truth I'm talking about a situational
truth I enjoy eating a Chipotle is my
truth right it's a it's a preference
right or I feel angry about this that's
also my truth right yes yes and I can do
that in a way in fact you and I had a
conversation this week I got angry at
you about something and I told you I was
angry yeah that was the truth but I
didn't show you I was angry yeah didn't
say how dare you what the hell are you
doing I can't and you raised my voice
and yell and express outrage in reaction
to that anger yep but I also didn't hide
the truth from you because that wouldn't
be a good friend either in fact it would
probably harm the relationship because
then I will bottle it up and I'll have
that same resentment that I carry with
me and resentment is like mold it grows
and grows and grows and it makes us sick
yeah and so being politically correct in
the sense that like well I'm going to
avoid the truth I'm going to tell you
what is nice I'm going to be the
politician in this stance
well that's also not truth and that's an
accidental way to not batter them but
avoiding that truth will also create a
type of toxicity that will permeate the
relationship yeah being obsessed with
political correctness at the expense of
Truth is really just another way of
saying I value being liked more than I
value helping the people I love being
aligned with reality because when you
give people truth even if that truth
doesn't feel good you Empower them to
react and respond to their circumstances
with more knowledge right you are not
concealing reality from them but when we
say oh well I don't want this person to
not like me we're putting putting our
own ego above their own Evolution and
that's politically correct and it sounds
nice but is that really is that really
love that's right
Barbara I'd love to invite you I don't
know where you are but once a quarter
right now we're doing the Sunday
symposiums in Los Angeles and we've had
people travel from all over the place
our last one we had someone coming from
Germany which is wild they flew in from
Germany to come to our Los Angeles
Sunday Symposium we had someone from
Denver we had several people from Canada
we had at least two people who came up
from Mexico we've had people from New
York Upstate New York from Florida from
Texas now most people 80 percent are
from Southern California and they come
to these events we're building this
local Dogma free community but you're
welcome as well I'd love to give you a
couple tickets Barbara So Professor Sean
if you could put her on the guest list
if she reads reaches out to us you can
reach out to her and say thank you for
your question we'd love to have you at
Sunday Symposium it's only 200 people
and they're only a few tickets left to
that so if you want to join us Sunday
symposium.com it's Sunday March 26th at
noon and you can get on the email list
there you can sign up if for some reason
the the event is sold out you can get on
a wait list as well Barbara thank you
for your question let's check in with
our patreon live stream in a moment but
first real quick for right here right
now here's one thing that's going on in
the life of the minimalists did you know
that over on our patreon we just
published our 25th
home tour each week every Friday we do
the photo Friday home tour where we take
you inside our homes TK's home Ryan's
home my home and even Studio tours as
well Jordan did a whole five-part video
series as a studio tour as we were
building out the studio and so you're
welcome to check all that out
patreon.com the minimalist the 26th one
is just posted this week as well on the
private podcast we're gonna go into my
home we have 10 different photos this
week of my new home up in Ojai you can
check that out patreon.com the
minimalist and because it's happening
this weekend Professor Sean Professor
Sean and I teach a writing class uh two
or sometimes three times a year usually
a couple times a year we open up for 48
hours at a time it's called how to write
better and we take on 100 students and
we show you the whole process of
building the writing habit because we're
all writers now we all are sending text
messages and emails but some of us
aspire to do more more than that we want
to write blog posts or books or
marketing copy or Better Business emails
that entertain and Delight customers and
clients and co-workers
and you can do that the rising tide
lifts all boats here with writing and so
we show you how to write better the
parts of speech but also the writing
habit composition versus editing and
also how to publish your work whether
that's a blog or getting your book
published we have an entire week there
it's a four week online writing class it
opens up this weekend for 48 hours only
go to howtoritebetter.org get on the
email list there and we'll notify you as
soon as the course opens of course we'll
never send you spam or junk but we'll
let you know when the course opens one
quick word about how to write better I
had a teacher tell me once that when you
write well you develop your ability to
think well and we tend to think that
it's primarily the other way around if
I'm a good thinker then writing is just
the process of putting those thoughts on
paper but when you write you realize
that your thoughts tend to be a lot more
messy a lot more muddy than you may have
suppose and writing is a way of
clarifying your own assumptions your own
inferences and so on and then that trick
goes over into other areas of your life
when you learn to write well you can
think more clearly when you learn to
think more clearly you can communicate
more effectively with people in your
relationships and you can also process
your own emotions and identify specify
your goals more more effectively and so
on so writing well affects every area of
your life so that's my endorsement for
why you should aim to write well even if
it's not something that you want to do
as a profession yeah if you're if you
want to learn to write better
you're also learning to communicate
better to express yourself better but
also to better understand the world
around you to make sense of the chaos to
provide some order how to
writebetter.org if you're interested you
can also download my free ebook over
there it's called 15 ways to write
better and you can read in less than an
hour and walk away with 15 tips that
will improve your writing today
all right let's check out the live
stream Alabama we've got any questions
for us we sure do this question comes
from Lily my friend is having boundary
issues with her family she's quick to
call her family members narcissists but
seems to be lacking accountability how
can I support her through this we are
all narcissists on a scale right
do you have a mirror in your house then
of course you are a narcissist right
that's where it actually it comes from
the the idea of narcissism what's the uh
narcissist yeah yeah
all of a sudden he saw his this is
premirror he saw his reflection in the
water and became so in love with his own
image but isn't that what we do as well
this is who I am this is my identity we
get wrapped up in our job title we get
wrapped up in our activities we get
wrapped up in how compassionate we are
in fact we even develop an ego around
not having as big of an ego as the other
people around us that's also narcissism
and so narcissism isn't a bad thing or a
good thing it's recognizing it for what
it is it's just the ego that is wrapping
up your identity and saying this is who
I am as a person and as soon as you
understand that you start to develop
compassion for the narcissist next door
the solipsist next door because you
realize that's also me and some
alternate universe you know when I think
about labels like narcissists toxic
gas lighting which are very commonly
used phrases now those labels are useful
only when they guide us to insights that
allow us to take greater control over
our own experience but those labels can
also become a trap if we use them as a
basis for feeling self-righteous right
by declaring you as a narcissist I get
to feel better than you I get to feel
morally Superior to you by labeling you
as a gaslighter I get to feel good about
my own rightness and so on it's not that
these labels are untrue and that they
don't have a place but the labels are
only a means to an end once I've
identified that my situation is toxic or
that I'm being gaslit or that I'm
dealing with a narcissist what am I
going to do about it you know how am I
going to find the tools that I need to
better myself but what I would say
getting back to this
this question is you know a boundary
isn't a boundary if there is no
consequence for refusing to honor it now
a consequence doesn't have to be active
it doesn't have to be I'm going to punch
you in the chest if you violate this
boundary or I'm going to stop talking to
you forever but sometimes we confuse
boundaries with Bluffs we say I'm not
going to take that anymore well what
distinguishes that from a bluff
how do people know that that's not
something you're just saying but if they
cross that boundary reality is still the
same except you just feel a little more
frustrated
to articulate a boundary isn't to just
say what's unacceptable but it's also to
make clear what happens if what is
unacceptable is persisted in and that
requires you to be clear with yourself
about what you're willing to give up in
order to have what's important to you
let's check in with one more comment
from the patreon live stream what do you
got for us from Alabama here's a comment
from Angel she says my mom moved out of
state when my son was one month old
after begging me to have a baby once I
turned 18. it's incredible my mother's
mother was an amazing grandmother to me
because of that I expected my mother to
be an amazing grandmother to my kids and
she might have if I hadn't waited nine
years to have the baby she wanted me to
have
yeah needing someone else to have a baby
this is and Nedra talks about this quite
a bit in the book John le free we often
relive our parenting through our
grandkids oh I screwed all of these
things up I know as a parent I've
screwed up a bunch of things right and
if I could just go back to my 31 year
old self there's so many things I would
have done differently with Ella of
course right but of course I could say
that a decade from now as well if I
could just go back to my 41 year old
self there are so many things I would do
differently but that's that's the nature
of learning yeah that's right I mean
I'm sure my parents would be more proud
of me
had I been more successful earlier on
right or whatever like just take
whatever makes them proud of me if I had
done more of that at an earlier stage of
Life maybe they'd be more proud of me
there's no use in blaming yourself
for her lack of involvement and there's
no use in living in a hypothetical world
where you had that child earlier your
life is what it is you have the life
that you have that child is a gift and
all that matters now is you pouring your
love into your child and letting your
child know that you are the right person
for the right time that's what matters
and everyone who is meant to be a part
of that child's life will choose that
but I would say there's no point in
beating yourself up and blaming yourself
for other people's decision other
people's voluntary decision to be
involved or not be involved Nedra has a
few well she has this whole chapter in
her book called troubleshooting
relationships with parents and some of
the subsections that I read in there
about getting over your feelings with
respect to how you've been wronged right
healthy ways to manage anger as it pops
up again and again and again
and then how to stop hating your parents
isn't it fascinating the people we love
the most are the ones that we get the
most angry with because we have the most
expectations of those people you should
do this you should be this way and as
soon as you don't conform to that I get
really angry if the guy across the
street doesn't conform to my
expectations
I don't really think much about it right
yeah that's true but the people close to
me it's easy for me to batter them with
my own expectations malibam we're going
to check back in with the patreon live
stream on the private podcast but first
what else you got for us here's a
minimalist Insight from one of our
listeners
hi I'm Carrie from Denver with a tip
about answering the what do you do
question I love your advice about
answering that question by saying what
I'm passionate about but I found that my
answers were being dismissed a little
bit maybe because I'm a stay-at-home
model and there's a little bit of like
an entitled stigma attached to that role
so I tweaked my response now I answer
with I work really hard at maximizing
the things that matter most to our
family I'm an ambassador of purposeful
living so to speak and then I go on to
talk about writing and camping and the
other things that I'm passionate about
and ask the other person what they are
passionate about it's opened up some
really incredible conversations and I'm
so grateful for your advice
that's our minimal episode for today so
much more with Nedra over on the private
podcast this week we'll see on patreon
for the full two hour maximal edition of
episode 379 which includes answers to a
bunch more questions like how do we set
kind boundaries with people who thrive
on drama what are the best boundaries
for family members we've outgrown
especially regarding topics like
sexuality non-traditional lifestyle
choices and religion plus a million more
questions for Nedra and the minimalists
also this week we have a private
minimalist home tour 10 photos of my new
home up in Ohio we've got a new a
massive or trash it segment good TK get
rid of his blow dryer
just not TK it's one of our listeners
and she's wondering and it's a really
great question and by the way we have an
outstanding added value segment for you
how did I miss this album last year and
much much much more
of less if you want to hear all that
check out the minimalist private podcast
at patreon.com the minimalist or click
the link in the description to subscribe
and get your personal link so that our
weekly maximal episodes play in your
favorite podcast app you'll also gain
access to all of our podcast archives
all the way back to episode zero zero
one and if you're still on the fence
here's a testimonial from one of our
lovely patreon subscribers TG says you
guys are knocking it out of the park
several times a show I think he's
talking about utk he said the minimalist
private podcast is the most valuable
program I know of I'm so happy to be a
subscriber well thank you TG and big
thanks to Our Guest today Nedra tawab
her new book is called drama free it
comes out February 28th you can
pre-order it right now we'll put a link
to this book in the show notes
if you leave here today with just one
message
let it be this
love people
and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed or I bet that you'll be fine
without it foreign